découvrir
"Au revoir le bonheur",
son nouveau film tourné dans le
décor des îles-de-la-Madeleine.
Louis-Philippe OPhilippe OPhili.
- Il avait promis de venir
une dernière fois
avec nous aux Îles.
- "Au revoir le bonheur"
est un film sur la famille,,,
où quatre fils vivent
le décès de leur père.
ANTOINE BERTRAND et
PATRICE ROBITAILLE, comédiens
- J'ai l'impression que
c'est un film qui fait du bien.
C'est un film doux.
- On sait ce qu'il apporte,
c'est ça. Il apporte
de la douceur, il apporte
de la délicatesse,
de la bienveillance.
- On n'amène pas monsieur
Craquepout!
- Tandis que l'heure
est au recueillement,
les quatre orphelins se rendente
aux Îles-de-la-Madeleine pour
rendre un hommage au père
disparu. Il y aura des
mésententes entre ces quatre
personnages qui sont des
archét a l'épicurien,
le nostalgique, l'intellectuel
et l'homme d'affaires
sans scrupule.
LOUIS MORISSETTE et
FRANÇOIS ARNAUD, comédiens
- Pour moi, le personnage que
je défends, c'est pas un requin.
C'est juste qu'il regarde
les affaires sans émotion.
- Tu n'as pas vu le même film
que nous.
- Non non.
- Oui. Il est très cérébral,
alors que moi, je dirais
que je suis plus le coeur
du film.
- Voilà.
- Arrête Thomas,
je vais pas rater l'avion.
- "Au revoir le bonheur" estréat
aussi fait le film "Starbuck"
et signé le scénario
de "La Grande séduction", qui
se déroulait sur la Côte-Nord.
Pour s film,
la pandémie a obligé Ken Scott
à se tourner vers
les Îles-de-la-Madeleine.
KEN SCOTT,
scénariste et réalisateur
- On devait tourner ailleurs.
Au départ, c'étaitt, c'étaitt, u
qu'on allait tourner en
Provence, ensuite ça a été
La Havane. Mais à cause
de la pandémie, on pouvait plus
tourner à l'extérieur du pays.
Alors il a fallu ajuster.
- Papa a toujours dit
que la famille, c'est notre plus
grande richesse.
- Magnifique carte-poste
des Îles-de-la-Madeleine,
"Au revoir le bonheur"
met en scène une distribution
étincelante et inspirée
par le vent du large.
- On restait ensemble pendant...
Puis toi, tu as été
ines mêines mêines mêines mêinÎ?
- Sept, huit.
- Sept, huit semaines aux Iles,
donc tu as pas le choix
de t'imprégner, un, de la vie
là-bas, de comprendre un petit
us ce qu'ils vivent.
Puis on n'a pas eu le choix que
de devenir dans une espèce
de symbiose ensemble.
- Peux à Maxime
s'il te plaît.
- Oui, Maxime, il est où?
- Maxime!
- À cheval entre le drame,
la comédie et lae,
"Au revoir le bonheur" souffre
toutefois d'un scénario facile,
prévisible et léger. On est bien
loin de "La Grande séduction".
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, M